suite de notre série de reportages sur
les îles de la manche et de l'atlantique
après l'île de groix hier cap ce soir
sur celle du récent à l'extrême pointe
de la bretagne nord sur l'île d'ouessant
pendant des siècles on a été marin de
père en fils maryse burgot eric
georgeault ont rencontré l'un de ces
hommes qui ont donné toute leur vie à la
mère à l'heure où les premiers rayons de
soleil perce sur l'île d'ouessant paul
colin est en route pour sa pêche
quotidienne et il en est ainsi depuis
son premier jour de retraite pas chez
tous les matins de pas vrai elle appelle
des propos comme la plupart des hommes
d'ici c'est à la mer que paul colin a
donné sa jeunesse trente années de
marine marchande sur les pétroliers du
golfe persique 30 années à attendre ce
jour où il ne quitterait plus les
falaises de son île
sa vie de retraité c'est donc d'abord la
pêche pour le plaisir et cela même si la
relève des casiers et parfois décevantes
pour l'enjoindre de détruire là resté
presque une histoire de marins c'est
aussi forcément une histoire de femmes
de marins elle avait 20 ans quand elle
prit paul colin pour marie comme la
plupart des femmes d'ouessant elle fut
le plus souvent seul pour élever ses
quatre enfants elle aussi apprécient
donc aujourd'hui leur retraite paisible
les petits enfants viennent du continent
pendant les grandes vacances et ouvrent
grand leurs yeux pour leur grand mère
raconte la vie des femmes d'ouessant je
vous pensez bien que contre 6 mois on
avait quand même hâte de les voir
rentrer ça c'est évident et folle et les
enfants c'est parce que ça faisait quand
même un pont bretons loin et vous
messieurs vous aviez envie de rentrer
aussi justement ça pour l'approché des
congés de pouvoir compter pour partir
c'est certain demaret attendre oui et
autrefois les épouses des marins doux et
sans élever des moutons
c'était l'époque où lille comptait
jusqu'à 6000 bête sur la lande une
tradition agricole qui commencent à
disparaître comme a disparu l'époque où
les hommes d'ouessant n'avait d'autre
choix que de prendre la mer